let's talk about taboos people writing
in and saying should politics and
religion be taboo and conversation with
significant others with family with your
significant others family at work etc so
the way I grew up was politics and
religion are just like any other topics
you talk about them with your family
your immediate family at larger family
gatherings with friends etc sometimes
there are disagreements sometimes there
are not but assuming nobody is espousing
some truly violent disgusting position
you talk about politics and religion
just like you do anything else and then
everybody's still friends and
everybody's still respectful and and the
like I actually now have an even
stronger position on this because online
discourse and social media expose people
to political discussion that is the
worst you can imagine I actually think
it would be particularly beneficial for
kids from a young age to be exposed to
discussions about politics and religion
that are respectful and that don't
devolve into personal attacks because
unfortunately if at home politics and
religion aren't being discussed if it's
school politics and religion aren't
being discussed if for ever else they're
not being discussed and the model people
have is from Twitter we're really really
screwed and people end up not knowing
how to peacefully disagree with each
other how to respectfully express
opinions that aren't the same and then
just to go back to living with each
other or working with each other every
disagreement is seen as a personal
attack people often become triggered
it's not good and we all benefit from
talking about our views and we benefit
from having them challenged and we
benefit from not having topics be
off-limits now this doesn't mean you
ignore decorum or politeness or or don't
use common sense right if you're on a
first date maybe you do talk about
politics or maybe you don't now very
often politics and religion can be the
difference maker whether two people are
compatible so maybe you do want to talk
about it right away
maybe you leave it for the second or the
third date I don't know if it's your
first time meeting your significant
others parent
maybe you skip politics and religion
that one time not because you aren't
comfortable discussing it respectfully
with whoever but simply for for decorum
and to avoid disagreements in the
interest of establishing what hopefully
will be a long term relationship so use
your judgement don't you apply common
sense I think there's one other element
of this that's important to mention not
only are some topics taboo like politics
and religion but we also have a big
deficit of critical thinking skills and
skills with which we can examine our own
beliefs and how we came to our
conclusions and I think that if we want
to go in the direction of removing the
taboo around talking about politics and
religion where your quote not supposed
to we do need people who are better
informed about how to apply critical
thinking and basic epistemology skills
overall though I think we should be
doing more discussion of topics that
often become emotionally charged not
less and there has been no more
important time to be talking about
politics and religion and subjects that
can be difficult in all scenarios of
course again applying common sense if
you disagree let me know we've got a
great bonus show for you today get a
membership almost instantly by signing
up at join pakman.com